Asalamu allayikum.
Uh my name is Rafika Dei. I'm a medical
doctor. My field is holistic integrative
medicine. Uh I'd like to ask
>> you you're a doctor and your field is
>> holistic integrative medicine.
>> Holistic integrative medicine.
Uh I'd like to ask uh the taps or deep
meaning uh in uh Quran albakoro verse uh
Indeed, those who believed and those who
were Jews or Christians or those among
them who believed in Allah and the last
day and did righteousness
will have their reward with their lord
and no fear will there be concerning
them nor will they grieve. Uh my
question is uh
>> can you go straight to your question?
>> What I already knew was that those who
would find security, peace and freedom
from sadness and fear were those who had
faith who had surrendered meaning they
had become Muslims. How could this first
state that Jews, Christians and Sabines
could could also experience this? Thank
you.
>> Sister asking you a question based on
the verse of the Quran surah bakla
chapter 2 vers 62. It's also repeated in
surah maida that if you are a Jew or a
Christian if you believe in the Quran
and believe in a god you shall get the
best of life. So the question is that
how can the Jews and the Sabians
how can they get the best how will they
be safe what you have to understand that
this verse if you read the tapas as you
asked me to mention it's talking about a
question that can the Sabians can the
Jews can the Christians
can they go to Jenna if they accept
Islam why not
The reply to this if you cross check
with the Quran. The Quran says in
chapter 3 verse number 110.
Oh we Muslims are the best of peoples
you want for mankind.
Because we enjoying what is good and we
forbid what is wrong and we believe in
Allah.
If the people of the book had faith, it
would have been better for them.
Among them, there are some who are
that majority of poverty transgressors.
So the Quran says among the there are
some who are M.
Example
if you know at the time of the prophet
the relative of Khadijah may Allah be
pleased with her.
He had prophesized
that Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he will be taken out of the country by
his own people and if I'm alive I will I
will support him he was a Christian he
was minimal mine so Allah says in the
Quran that there are some Christians who
are M. So this verse according to me
refers to those Christian those
Jews who are M
>> not general Jews. There are several
verses talking about them that they on
the wrong path. How can the Quran
contradict? Quran is not contradicting.
So the cross reference I believe that
this verse refers to those people who
those who will accept dean. There are
two taps. One of the muffins say that
can they go to Jenna? Yes, if they
accept Islam they go to Jenna if they
believe
and among them there are some M or two
believers but majority of poverty
transgressors. Hope that answers the
question.
>> Yeah. Uh I already knew about Jews and
uh Christian but I don't really
understand about Sabiin. What is the
meaning of it? Sabiin.
>> Sabin is another group of people. People
say they may be the fire worshippers,
the Sabians, may be the fire
worshippers, may be the paris,
that's another we know the Jews, we know
the Christian, there are people that
came in between and some of the muasar
say they may be the paris maybe. Hope
that's answer.
>> Thank you.